[Musique]
le Conseil constitutionnel proclame élu
président de la République quand le
Conseil consuel a été créé il prenait 5
décisions par an donner de la substance
à ses droits constitutionnels
aujourd'hui le Conseil constitutionnel
prend 100 décisions par an ça donne
toute sa place à l'état de droit le
Conseil constitutionnel mode d'emploi le
contrôle a priori de la loi épisode 4
pour juger a priori c'est-à-dire avant
qu'elle ne soit promulguée de la
constitutionnalité de loi le Conseil
peut être saisi de deux façons à
l'origine ce sont le président de la
République le Premier ministre le
président de l'Assemblée nationale où
celui du Sénat qui peuvent chacun saisir
le Conseil mais depuis 1974 lors d'un
vote d'une oie avant qu'elle ne soit
promulgué 60 députés ou 60 sénateurs ont
le pouvoir de saisir le Conseil
constitutionnel
[Musique]
je viens chercher le clip de l'Assemblée
nationale exemple ce matin les singes
sont saisis par plus de 60 députés et
plus de 60 sénateurs sur la loi dite
sécurité globale 2 une loi qui vise
notamment introduire notre droit un
cadre légal à l'utilisation des drones
par les autorités une fois enregistré
par le Secrétariat général c'est saisine
est envoyé aux membres du Conseil ils
ont un mois pour rendre une décision de
constitutionnalité la question qui nous
est posée c'est est-ce que oui ou non
cette disposition législative est
conforme aux droits ou contraire au
droit et l'instruction débute par la
rédaction par le secrétaire général le
service juridique d'une première note
d'analyse qui doit contribuer à éclairer
la décision des 9 sages alors comment ça
marche pour toute décision jeune homme
un rapporteur
ce rapporteur étudie la question
attentivement il travaille avec nos
juristes et il élabore un projet de
décision
ce projet de décision arrive devant
notre collège nous en discutons au sujet
des drones ça présente une utilité pour
lutter contre un certain nombre de
délits mais ça prend aussi des dangers
si vous suit à la trace et qu'on regarde
où vous allez
confirme l'intérieur de votre domicile
qu'on connecte le film avec la
reconnaissance faciale qu'on garde ça
pendant plusieurs années dans les
dossiers ça donne des régimes qui ne
sont pas exactement des régimes
conformes à ce qu'on veut pour la France
nous devons pouvoir dire est-ce que oui
ou non la loi a respecté l'État de droit
nous avons dit dans ce texte hier dans
notre décision le précédent texte avait
été annulé celui-là est meilleur et
voilà ce qui est acceptable et voilà sur
quoi ça porte ça pose encore des
questions saisis sur quatre articles de
la loi relatives à la responsabilité
pénale et la sécurité intérieure le
Conseil censure partiellement les
dispositions relatives recours au drone
dans le cadre de la police
administrative et a sorti de 5 réserves
d'interprétation le reste des
dispositions contestées comme la
vingtaine de décisions de
constitutionnalité prise par an cette
décision s'impose à toutes les autorités
publiques et juridictionnelles et ne
peut faire l'objet de recours
[Musique]